it's a sound that Duke of Sussex has
been accustomed to throughout his life
the camera shutters welcoming his
arrival to Canada that peaceful new life
might not be so peaceful after all the
clamor for news back home is as intense
as ever at a photo of the Duchess
walking with baby Archie in the Canadian
woods has attracted the threat of legal
action from the couple the peace and
quiet of this part of Canada is what
attracted them here their temporary home
down this lane on a private estate has
become a magnet for those seeking
pictures however far they are from the
UK they remain newsworthy American
photography could be a problem I think
they could go up to Vancouver if the
couple stay there and they could base
there for you know weeks months on end
to get whatever the next story is it
could be the couple having a row it
could be a couple kissing holding hands
announcing a pregnancy anything you know
that they want to be there for to get
that moment the local newspapers on
Vancouver Island are doing their best to
give them space to make them feel
protected here places like this where
the Duchess has been spotted suddenly at
the center of huge interest and Canada
doesn't have the kind of code of conduct
for newspapers like they have in the UK
the celebrity privacy laws haven't been
tested in court and across the border is
the US where the paparazzi see
celebrities as open season histories
told us that photos of the Royals off
guard are big business this one of Diana
with Dodi fired among a set that was
sold worldwide for a million pounds
hounding of Harry's mother may well have
been from a different era as the then
Kate Middleton found times have only
changed so much and imposing controls on
the media abroad is another matter
all-together when you're a royal on tour
you do get a degree of protection it's
heavily choreographed but I think it
might be the time where the raw rotor
has to widen out and there has to be
more access more questions allowed that
that's up to the rows but certainly as
private individuals they won't have that
restriction
a couple is already fighting legal
battles with newspapers back home as
they exit the Royal bubble they're
entering a world far more out of their
control
Greg Milam Sky News Vancouver Island